Wan-Teh: My name is
Wan-Teh Chang.
I'm going to talk about
the network stack in Chromium.
A few minutes ago I sent
the URL for the slides
to Chrome team--the Chrome team
email address.
So if you have a laptop,
you can search for an email
from me.
And then you can look
at the slides.
So when a user types in a URL--
a universal resource locator--
the browser need to fetch
the resource from the network.
And the network stack is
a component of Chromium
that actually goes
through the network to do that,
and also potentially
caches the resource
for the next time.
It's amazing that in the short
history of Chromium,
we have already written
the network stack price.
originally we started using
the WinINet library,
which is really a component
of IE.
And we did that to get something
working very quickly.
And also, we believe that after
more than ten years at the web,
every OS should have a very good
BOT and HTTP library.
And we believe
that should be the case
for all the three major
platforms.
But we ran
into some problems,
so we switched to another
library called
WinHTTP on Windows.
And it works mostly
just fine.
So that's what--
WinHTTP is actually
what's shipping in Chrome 1.0.
But gradually we will run into
some imitations of WinHTTP.
It's very difficult
to overcome those
without a source code.
I'll just name one example
is that
you cannot use WinHTTP
to download a file
larger than two gigabytes.
And these days,
with these dvd-rom images,
there are a lot of downloads
that are larger than that.
and there is no way
for us to overcome that.
So last July we started
to realize that
it's really time to write
our own network stack.
And also we believe that
that will also help
the porting effort
to Mac and Linux.
So in Chrome 2.0 beta,
we are using our own
cross-platform network stack.
And this also--
One reason I mentioned earlier
is that it allows us
to fix bugs easier.
But we also have a lot of ideas
to improve performance.
So this allows us
to experiment with those ideas.
So in the source code, all
of our network stack source code
is under a single directory net.
And then under that, there are
several sub-directories.
And most of them have
very obvious names, like HTTP.
The HTTP subdirectory contains
the implementation
of the HTTP protocol.
And then, similarly, there is
another subdirectory for FTP.
And then there is
a subdirectory called
url_request.
And for most of you, that
directory is the most important
because that's really--
The rest of Chrome uses
the network stack.
They issue a URL request.
And the URL request
will create
the appropriate proto handle
to handle that URL request.
We also have a subdirectory
called proxy
to handle proxy
and get our system
proxy settings and so on.
And then there is a directory
underneath called Base--
Underneath Net called Base,
which contains the basic
socket implementation--SSL--
certificate handling,
and so on.
We also have our own test
that is only used
for our unitest.
So the network stack
is actually something
that is possible to use
independent of Chromium.
It has very little dependency
on the rest of Chromium.
We only depend
on three other components...
The Base component...
The V8 JavaScript interpreter
you only use for interpreting
the proxy auto-config files.
We also use the Google URL
library.
And then we use just a few
open-source libraries
to decode HTTP content
decoding, such as Zzip or Gzip.
So that's pretty much it.
And most of the code is
cross-platformed.
We hide platform-dependency
in a small number of files.
So if you need to port
the network stack
to a new platform,
you would just need to provide
the OS bindings
for RTCP sockets--
SSL sockets--
get in the system,
process settings.
Or how to access
the system certificate store.
That's it.
Then, if you need to use
the network stack,
it's useful to know
the threading model
and the IO model.
The threading model is
mostly single-threaded.
So we do most of the work
a single thread
called the IO thread.
This is useful to know
because this is why
a lot of data structures
in the network stack
don't need to be protected
by a lot.
And the IO model is
an asynchronized IO model.
So this means you initiate
an IO operation,
and we return immediately
a status code that says
it's in progress.
And then, when
the IO operation is done,
like the read, you say,
"I want to read."
When the data is received,
we will invoke your
Completion Callback
provided by you
on the same IO thread.
So they're just the model
we're using.
And this actually is true
for most of the classes
in the network stack,
except for the top level--
URL request class.
For that class we have
a delegate class
that provide more ways
to invoke the callbacks
for multiple events.
Then the next slide
is how the network stack
is integrated with Chromium.
The network stack, because
it needs to access the network,
is a privileged operation.
So it has to run
inside the browser process.
The renderer is the one
that actually initiates
the loading of a resource
that starts from WebCATS.
The web--internet engine.
So that load resource request
goes through IPC
to the browser process.
And then there is a class
in the browser process
called the resource
dispatcher host.
That is responsible
for issuing
the URL request
from the renderer processes
through the network stack.
So that is a very important
entry point
into the network stack.
But there is another
entry point
into the network stack
called the URL fetcher.
And that is used
only for URL requests,
generated by Chromium itself.
Such as visiting
the safe-browsing server,
or carrying navigation
suggestions,
or sending usage statistics
to our UMA servers.
So at this point I'm going
to turn over to Eric Roman
to go into the network stack
in more detail.
Roman: Hey, so I'm gonna talk
a little bit about
the programming model
for how you actually end up
issuing network requests,
and some of the layers
that we'll pass through
as you do this.
So the main header file
you'd want to check,
if you're going to be
programming a network request,
is urlrequest.h.
And this describes how to use
the URL request objects,
which is the main entry point
into the network stack.
So when you construct
the URL request,
you're going to specify
the URL that you want to fetch,
as well as the URL request
delegate object.
And the delegate object is
how you receive notification
of events
during the network fetch.
So you'll get--
you specify, essentially,
callbacks for when
the response has started.
When the response has completed.
When you get a repeater act,
when authentication's required.
And so the URL request object,
once you've constructed it,
you just call "start,"
and it begins
issuing the stuff synchronously,
and your delegate will
get called
to notify those various events.
So the other thing you have
to specify to your request
is the URL request context.
And the context is essentially
the global state
that's shared between
network requests.
So this includes
the cookie store,
the HTTP cache, the various
network session state...
auth cache,
the client socket pool,
and proxy service.
And usually
the URL request contacts...
you can think of it
as one per browser.
And so all requests
you do
will be sharing
this same state.
So they share
the same cookie store.
They share the same
HTTP cache.
The exception is
with incognito mode,
where you'd actually specify
a different URL request contact
that you can substitute in
an in-memory cookie store,
and in-memory cache.
So I guess we'll just
step through a sample request--
what happens
when you issue,
let's say an HTTPS
or HTTP request.
So if you have the--
Can you hear me?
So if you have the slides,
you can follow along
on those as well.
I'll try and reproduce
the similar diagram.
Okay, so, we'll start with
the URL request object.
The arrows here represent
dependencies
and sort of flow
of execution.
So we're going to pass in
the delegate object,
which is how we get called back
when events complete.
And we also pass
the URL request contacts,
which holds all
of our global state.
So we're first going to
pass into the--
The URL request is going to
look at the scheme of the URL.
It's going to determine
what type of job to create.
So since we support FTP file,
URLs, HTTP, HTTPS,
this is where it determines
which specific type of jobs
used for this request.
So in our hypothetical
situation,
we'll be using
an HTTPS request.
So what it's going to do is
it's going to create
a URL request HTTP drop.
And the URL request HTTP drop,
at this layer,
it applies filters.
And it's also going to read
and write the cookie store.
So we'll just write
the cookie store here.
And the cookie store
comes from
the URL request contacts.
So after--we're going to
go down to the next layer.
This is the HTTP cache
transaction.
And this is going to enforce
the HTTP cache stuff.
So it also has a dependency now
for more stake
coming from the URL request
contacts,
which is the HTTP cache.
And that's also
part of URL requests contacts.
So if the HTTP--
If the request
can be serviced from cache,
it's gonna stop at this layer,
and sort of return that.
If not, then it's going to
have to actually do
a real transaction
on the network.
So it's going to go down
to the next layer,
which is the HTTP network
transaction.
And this is where
the real details
of the HTTP protocol
are implemented.
So reading and writing
the headers,
understanding response codes--
most of that logic is
in HTTP network transaction.
And it's going to, like,
apply authentication,
apply the proxy.
So at this layer,
it's going to rely
on quite a bit of state
from URL request contacts.
And most of this is
in HTTP network session.
So this is indirectly part
of URL request contacts.
It's contained in that.
And so your HTTP session
contains various things.
IT contains the HTTP cache...
the client socket pool,
proxy service.
A lot of stuff from here
as well.
So we'll draw in
a couple of those.
Okay, and then, so now we're
near the bottom of the stack.
And now we hav--the final levels
are the socket levels.
So if this were an HTTP request,
we'd be talking
to the client socket interface.
We'd be talking to
SSL client socket.
So we'll just put that
in here.
And so this would essentially
wrap a transport socket,
which would just be
our TCP client socket.
And then, obviously, here
we're actually just
talking down to the network.
So lastly,
just gonna talk a little
about the tests.
So if you're going to be
working the network stack,
and you make modifications,
you obviously want
a unit test.
So to run the unit test,
you just use the net unit test
target.
And most of the tests use
mock dependencies.
For, like, at the socket level
or, you know,
mock proxy services,
whatever.
There are some exceptions.
As once I mentioned,
we also have the test server.
And the test server is
a Python application,
where you can create
custom responses
or handlers for special tests.
So that's also an option.
So, yeah.
And there's a bunch
of resources for--
You can check out
the network stack road map,
the DNS prefetching document
page.
There's documentation
on disk cache,
if you want more information.
There's some links
in the slides.
And I guess lastly,
Wan-Teh and I can
answer questions.
Yes.
man: So Wan-Teh mentioned
reasons for switching away
from WinINet and and WinHTTP.
Can you guys reiterate
some of the other reasons
besides the two-gigabyte
file download limit on WinHTTP?
Why we ended up ditching,
like, WinINet, for example?
So the question was to elaborate
a bit on, you know,
why we chose to ditch WinINet
and WinHTTP.
So he mentioned
there were some bugs.
in particular, like,
not being able
to do file downloads
over two gigabytes,
and with some other--
I think Wan-Teh will--
Wan-Teh: So with WinINet,
we basically ran into
two major problems.
The first one is that
we cannot get the certificate--
the service certificate.
And this is critical
when you handle
an SSL certificate error.
So that one we actually went
to extraordinary measure--means.
And we were able
to get the certificate
by patching WinINet.
But the other one
that we cannot surmount
was that it's impossible
to tell WinINet
to bypass its own cache.
And we know that some server
generates dynamic content
based on the browser's
user agent.
So we do not want to share
the cache with IE.
So that's really the reason
we had to switch
to a new library.
For WinHTTP, we could tell
that it shares some code
with WinINet.
But probably because
it's not used in IE.
The shared code is older,
so it has some bugs.
Security bugs that had already
been fixed in IE's version.
So we are quite unhappy
about that.
And it also had some problem
that caused system crashes--
blue screens on some laptops.
That one we were also able
to find--work around.
But in the end we just thought
that there are
too many issues.
And the porting to Mac
and Linux was going to start.
So we thought it's time
to write our own.
man: So on Mac and Linux,
what's the lay of the land
with regard to existing platform
network implementations,
and whether they're
better or worse?
The same for us as--
Wan-Teh: Okay.
So Peter asked about the system
networking libraries
on Mac and Linux,
and their quality.
On the Mac,
I know there is a library
called CFNetwork.
I guess it stands for
Core Foundation Network.
That's used by Safari.
So I thought that should be
pretty good.
But I don't have any
personal experience using it.
Linux, the usual problem is
not whether there is one.
The problem is
there are too many,
and you need to pick one.
So I thought on Linux--
we were considering LibCurl.
That's quite popular.
And there's another one
called Lib Neon
that's used by the SBN client.
I think both would
probably work well.
But in the end, we just thought
it better to write our own.
And the network stack,
it turns out,
is not really that complicated
Especially the core portion.
So basically Darin Fisher
wrote it within a week.
And it was able to do TCP--
regular TTP requests--
HTTP requests.
man: I'm just curious.
Are we headed in the direction
of being able
to have our own proxy settings
and our own certificate store,
and not rely on the system
for that?
Um, okay...
so the question is--
Right now we're using
the system proxy settings
and the system certificate
store.
So the question is whether
we're going to support
our own proxy settings
and a certificate store.
I think the answer is--
I have two different answers.
For a certificate store,
I still think
it's very important to share
the system cert store
with other applications.
And we haven't received
any complaints
about our using
the Windows system store.
But with the proxy settings,
we do get a lot of complaints
from some Firefox users.
Basically,
their problem is that
they use
the same laptop at work
and at home.
And they have to use
the system proxy settings
with IE at work.
But for some reason
they want to use--
When they use Firefox,
they want to use
a different set of settings
that's appropriate
for their home network.
And these Firefox users
told us
that they cannot use Chrome
because of this reason.
So we are seriously
considering adding
our own proxy settings.
man: What are the real-world
web-compat ramifications
of different network stacks,
especially rolling our own?
Wan-Teh: So the question is
what are the real-world
ramifications
of network stacks?
Especially when writing
our own.
man: For website compatibility.
Wan-Teh: our experience is
that--
So working on network, I think,
is similar to our layout.
On the one hand, you need
to implement a standard.
But on the other hand,
you also need to be
somewhat permissive
of broken implementations.
So our approach has been that
we're trying to be
as strict as possible.
And when we run into
incompatibility,
we make our best effort
to contact the site,
to correct it.
Or sometimes contact--
if they are using open-source
server product,
we try to file a bug report.
But usually that takes
a lot of effort.
So we also have to implement
work-arounds
for some
of the incompatibilites.
Any other questions?
Okay, thank you.
[applause]